你换一个老公，
什么事儿都出去，
买双鞋，
要跟老婆请示一下，
给爸妈800块钱，
什么事都愿意听老婆的，
老婆你做主，
但是他一个月挣5000，
一年挣6万，
你换还是不换？
我跟我老公是结婚，
怎么样，
小孩中班，
我老公是自己创业，
嗯，
我帮他打理一下，
做出卖，
开开票这种我的重心是在家庭，
我最近呢发现我老公瞒着我给我公婆转钱，
这个事情呢，
我本身我也想过肯定是要赡养父母，
但是他瞒着我吧，
我就心里有点不是滋味，
因为我的孩子的话，
是我妈妈把我带到四周岁，
现在是我自己在带，
我就在想对于这个事情我是否要直接去问，
因为我也不想跟他吵架，
我就怕我到时候问的不好就要吵，
厂家就是很费精力的一件事情，
那我觉得这个事情是这么看的，
一呢是要看咱们家庭年收入，
一年大概收入是多少，
二呢是要看主要收入的人是谁，
三呢是要看他给他爸爸妈妈转钱的这个金额额度，
是不是在恶意的转移夫妻共同的财产，
我觉得这三点最关键，
所以你跟我说一下，
你们的家庭收入，
年收入多少钱，
主要是靠他还是主要是靠谁，
他给他妈妈转账没有告诉你那个金额是多少，
我们来判断一下，
我们收入还行，
大概一两百个有的，
那主要肯定是我老公，
因他是这样的，
那我只是怀疑啊，
因为我发现他每个月有一笔固定的那种提现多少钱。
起就是五六千这样的，
我最近发现是可能比如说6500啊，
像这种他可能实际存的话，
应该是会凑个整吧，
那我就不知道了，
最近是存了多少过去，
那如果是这种情况的话，
那我的答案就非常明确，
这个答案就是闭嘴，
你假装不知道闭嘴啊，
我要伤夫妻的和气，
不要伤感情啊，
那为他如果一直这么我一直闭嘴，
为什么呢？
他对于他的年收入来说的话，
是一个月就是五六千块钱，
一年五六万块钱的话都不算什么啊，
他是这样的，
他之前也转了一笔，
好像转了七八万吧，
然后现在就是每个月这样子在那个转，
我估计可能十几个，
应该是有转过去，
不要去撕破这些东西，
两口子过日子，
反过来讲，
如果有一天你一年挣200万，
你知道你老公这个人就有点那啥，
你要是跟他讲的话，
挺难沟通的，
假设你会不会给你爸妈娶个五千六千的，
一个月给爸妈当生活费一样的，
这样肯定是要养的，
我之前也就是他难着我，
我觉得有点就换作是你，
你一年挣200万啊，
现在假设你一年挣200万哦，
你觉得有必要为了这五六千块钱开始商量一下的，
没必要。
还有一个比如说，
虽然说我老公给他们这个数目啊，
但是他们一年可能就过年给孩子的压岁钱可能就几百，
心里我就觉得吧，
那我挣压岁钱我要收吗？
姐妹，
把时间战线拉长一点，
我老婆都是你们的吗？
那不一定呢，
我。
老公有一个姐姐，
我公公就老是贴补她，
姐姐你知道吗？
我就感觉有点好来，
今天我再问你一的问题，
如果让你换一个老公，
她什么事都愿意跟你商量，
什事儿都征求你的意见，
但她一年挣6万块钱，
一个月就挣5000，
你换不换吧，
我懂，
姐妹们真的让你换一个老公，
什么事都啊，
出去买双鞋要跟老婆请示一下，
给爸妈800块钱要跟老婆请示一下，
什么事都愿意听老婆的，
老婆你做主，
但是他一个月挣5000，
一年挣6万，
你换还是不换？
那不换就这个逻辑了，
而且你还得表现出来，
对公公婆婆还得感谢感恩，
还得表现出来，
公公婆婆愿意给孩子包红包的话，
还得教育孩子感恩，
这样你们两口子才能有长久的日子过下去。
好的，
换我真的啊，
我对你掏心掏肺的讲，
就是这件事儿闭嘴，
因为换做是你的话，
你也会这么干的，
当你一年能挣200万的时候，
你也会觉得我有什么好商量的，
我一年能挣200万，
我给我爹妈转个三五千，
五千八千的，
我还需要跟你商量吗？
你也会有这种心态，
不是主要是觉得吧，
我公婆小孩他们也没给我带，
我也是让我妈妈来帮我带的，
因为那时候我还在上班呢，
你公婆对你和你公婆对她儿子，
这是两条线，
不好，
那就这个事儿是吧，
想通了再说好，
我为啥那么理解这个男的，
你看我现实生活中和这个男的是一样的，
你说我给我爸妈一年花多少钱，
我还要征求一下我对象的同意吗？
将心比心啊，
我明白了吧，
所以我就笃定，
我笃定刚才连麦的这个。
朋友，
当你一年能挣200万的时候，
你根本就没有这个想法，
说要跟你对象商量一下，
要给你爸妈多少钱，
完全没有这个必要，
需要做的就是好不容易妹妹你命好，
找了个老公，
一年能挣200万，
这把牌可不是说谁轻而易举就能拿到的，
一把牌你就得想尽办法，
我怎么能把手上这把牌拽的好好的，
打的平平顺顺的，
打出一个人顺的大开局。
听明到啊，
但凡你老公一年挣钱大几十万的，
几百万的啊，
你都给我大方一点，
不要盯着那个三千五千，
五千八千的那个事儿啊，
学会了没有，
你都给我大方一点，
要有一个经营者的思路，
经营者的思路是什么？
一个一年能挣200万的公司，
他不可能没成本，
一定要把你这个家庭当一家公司来看，
一家公司一年盈利200万，
她不可能没有成本，
她成本不可能说十万八万就能打得住的，
她的成本就干到30万，
你也能赚170万，
我真的希望我直播间的这些姐妹们啊，
好不容易找到一个能挣钱的对象的话，
你就真的一定要珍惜啊，
一定要过好这个日子啊，
千万别作没了，
你要是这作没了之后，
你当时二婚，
你带这个孩子你怎么搞啊？
你上哪儿找一个一一年挣200万的老公替你们着急，
我还恨不得替你过日子了。
记得点赞关注哦。